all right hello everyone how are you
guys doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day and today oh I got I got a
compliment hey hey hey um and today we
are here with episode three of finding
the best
merchesi things with 100 Mil for 1 hour
so today the category will be flipping
the highest margins category on G
tracker they are a sponsor of mine and I
will be using them throughout the
episodes if you guys want to check them
out they will be in the description down
below but they are very helpful
providing margins and I look to kind of
show that here today so without further
Ado let's go ahead and I will go on over
to the site right now I'm looking at it
right now and there is actually a really
good merch that I'd like to do that
really could help us out so let's head
on over all right so this is where I
want to be so basically I went to
highest margins and now I'm going to
sort by highest profit so as you guys
can see an elijan has about a 9 mil
margin right now can't merge that
however with 100 Mil so what I'm going
to look to right now is probably this
imbued heart and band's ornament kit the
ornament kit I I know I could buy a
couple of um I also kind of want to buy
something that's more high volume
something like primordial boots who have
an 83k margin right now which is really
nice but uh I can't do all of that at
once so we're going to kind of have to
pick and choose right now I think I'm
going to go with the imbued heart and
probably a couple Mill over on the
band's ornament kit and then I'll find
something else from there all right so
before we get into the video I just
wanted to kind of give you guys a good
for warning that the way that I set up
this video and doing it within 1 hour
isn't the best way to do these types of
items items with the biggest mark
margins are typically going to be some
of the slowest merching items in the
game if you look at the buying and
selling quantity per hour of the items
that I checked out over on GE tracker
they were all around 2 to four which is
very low and means sometimes you aren't
even going to be able to buy and sell
some of those items within the hours you
guys will come to see in the video also
I'd like to say that at some points in
the video my keyboard kind of goes a
little crazy cuz my mic was a little too
close to it and it is a little annoying
but I don't think it's overly it is too
overpowering so hopefully you guys can
get past that with that being said let's
get into the video all right so there we
go got the timer going so what I'm going
to do now is go ahead and throw in an
offer for an imbued heart I believe and
uh I got to buy this for SE
67.72 so going to go ahead and do that
and then uh I think we'll do a couple
bandal orament kits and I'll update you
when I got all the offers in all right
not exactly what I was looking for but
uh I guess I'll take it so apparently
the uh the margins have changed since I
last did it but I still think I can make
a decent amount of money off this so I'm
going to go ahead and sell it for this
hopefully and uh we'll go from there so
that wouldn't be too bad of a profit
right there all right so now going to go
check the margins on heavy ballistas
myself just to make sure that they are
what they are I believe we'll be able to
buy and sell off a decent amount of
these before uh before the hour is over
hopefully I know with their recent nerve
they're not going to be as you know
sought after but there we go that's a
decent margin we'll go ahead and take
that good 50k all right so there you go
as you guys can see I have everything or
all of my cash pretty much dispersed
right now now everything has a decent
margin on them right now the Arcane or
not the Arcane but the ancient Pages
have like 130k which is insane for those
the banders ornament kits are like 225
andb Hearts around to 300K Fury ornament
kit um the fury ornament kit GTH and SS
and heavy ballistas are all between 50
and 70k so it's not that bad at all and
uh hopefully we'll be able to do
something decent here all right so I'm
actually really surprised within the
first few minutes we've already had a
lot of stuff sell so right or buy SL
sell so one of the ballistas have sold
on we've ended up buying four an ancient
Pages bought and then also the imbued
heart which was a huge merch just ended
up selling off that was I don't even
know how much that was like almost 500k
so I'm going to go ahead and do that
again and yeah let's let's see what we
can do all right so with this we've kind
of reached a problem um I see we're only
at 43 minutes so we kind of need to get
to selling some of this stuff but uh
yeah I'm going to list this stuff down
just a little bit because I think I
might have got an undercut on that which
isn't too big of a deal but I just want
to get it out of here also have four
ancient Pages now sitting here and I
don't know what the actual price is for
them I guess I could refresh a site
probably that would be a good idea all
right so oh now armadel page 3es are
really good oh God ancient page all
right come on now you got to be kidding
what what ancient Pages now say that I
have the Buy offer come on no I don't
want that I don't want that all right so
I'm going to go ahead and buy an ancient
page what was I doing three I think so
no ancient page two okay
[Music]
all right so since I have a lot of
ancient Pages I'm going to go ahead and
buy one right now and uh yeah we'll see
how that goes so as you guys can see
this one didn't buy for 300K so I'm
going to leave these in for 300K if
these all sell that means I'd make about
270k I think off of them or no I'd make
almost I'd make almost 400k off of those
which would be really nice and then
right now it says armadel page 3es are
really good so I'm going to go ahead and
check out that and Arad page three so it
says I can buy it for
420k lit um but yeah I'm going to go
ahead and buy what five is that how many
I can buy yeah we'll go ahead and buy
five so there hasn't been a lot of
movement on a lot of these things like
these three things in particular haven't
bought or sold at all so I might move
off of them I know the Bando ornament
kits are just really really iffy um but
they have a really good margin so I'm
going to keep them in there I know they
don't buy and sell a lot in hour so I
kind of have to be patient with them
however the Berserker necklace and the
fury ornament kits I might just back off
of because there aren't that big of
margins anyways and I could probably
find something else with a better margin
all right so from here it's kind of a
decision of what do I want to do do I
want to keep doing this imbed heart that
isn't buying and I'm going to say that I
don't because right now there's Abyssal
bludgeons it says that the buy and sell
per hour is really low for bludgeons
however I've personally done these
before and I don't think it's that low
so I'm going to go ahead Jesus Christ my
spelling I'm going to go ahead and try
to buy some bludgeons all right so there
we we go going to go ahead and try to
buy two bludgeons for 42127 and uh they
should have about a 200k margin on both
of them so hopefully we can hit that all
right there we go finally got an Abyssal
bludgeon to buy which is really exciting
also an armadel page 3 Jesus we haven't
had anything Buy in forever so I was
kind of getting a little nervous that I
wasn't going to make that much money
this video but there we go this should
be a good 200k coming in right here off
the bludgeon so yeah you're going to
sell that off then the armad page three
will actually be able to sell off for
about 120k profit if all goes well with
that one so uh going to go ahead and
list it up for
542k and we should be good to go on that
so Ranger boots right now apparently
have an 800k margin which is absolutely
insane and someone probably just got
pretty lucky to actually be able to buy
it for that however I'm going to go
ahead and try to do the same thing so I
ended up taking out some of my uh offers
on other things right now there's a
toxic staff as well that has a decent
margin so I might try to go and get that
not that one the other one all right so
this staff is uh doing doing pretty
decent right now so apparently I could
buy it for nine
968 and we'll be able to sell it on for
about 120k profit if that one or two I
guess is able to sell all right we will
uh go ahead and try out what what do we
want to try out this uncharge TR it
honestly though I did throw in an offer
for this just a little bit ago but it
was not buying so I'm going to go ahead
and try again and we'll see if this
one's able to buy so uh this is where we
got all of our offers at right now and
hopefully within the next 30 minutes
that's able to change a little bit all
right so we are nearing the end of the
hour we haven't had a a whole lot of
stuff by at this point I am going to try
to buy one of these ancient pages and
see what it ends up selling for or I
don't know I don't know what we're going
to do about them I have four of them and
they're not selling so it is what it is
but we had all this stuff sell off so I
think I'm just going to leave the rest
of the stuff in here just for a little
bit I don't know why I haven't had the
either of these things buy since they
are very high volume items or more high
volume than the rest of the things I've
been merching but uh yeah I feel like
this has been pretty decent if we get
these rage re booots bu in these final 2
and a half minutes I will be pretty
hyped though
uh for the most part I'm going to let
everything go ahead and sell off and
then uh I'll be back at the end but
there shouldn't be a whole lot of stuff
buying at this point my ears just
started bleeding due to this timer being
so loud so I'm going to go ahead and
take out all of the offers for the rest
of the stuff and then we'll wait for the
final little bit to sell all right so
there we go going to go ahead and dig
off the timer but uh as you guys can see
was able to sell off all the ancient
page twos so I'm going to go ahead and
collect that then on top of that with
the armad page three I'm just going to
go ahead and sell it off because I
really don't know what I'm supposed to
do with it right now so I'm just going
to go ahead probably could still make
money on this but I hasn't sold yet so
I'm just going to go ahead and dump it
that's pretty much the price I ended up
paying for it so as you guys can see we
made over a mill in this hour which in
and of itself is insane um especially
considering that a lot of the items that
you guys saw here today they are more
focused on a longer time frame so like
going to sleep or if you're going to
leave for a few hours those are items
that you really want to do because they
have very low like buying quantities
um so yeah it doesn't work the best with
this 1 hour setup that I did however I
was able to make 1.2 mil or almost 1.3
mil off of it so that's really good it's
a uh obviously a decent amount of GP
within an hour I would say but uh yeah
I'm pretty impressed with it if you guys
want to check out GE tracker go ahead
and do it in the description down below
if you guys enjoyed the video make sure
to hit the like if you guys want to see
more as soon as it goes live hit the sub
button anything you guys want to tell me
comment about it down below you guys
want to hit me up in game feel free to
message me on either account small exp
lamp or large exp lamp um 07 helpers is
a clan chat I chill in and the Twitter
is in the description down below
nonetheless hope you guys have a
wonderful day and peace
[Music]
y